Democratic presidential hopefuls have
spent more time at condemning a
president Trump than each other during
their fifth debate in the city of
Atlanta with the impeachment inquiry an
unavoidable backdrop 10 candidates took
the stage they included the frontrunner
Joe Biden Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren each heatedly making accusations
against mr. Trump although Bernie
Sanders said they shouldn't become
obsessed we have a president who is not
only a pathological liar he is likely
the most corrupt president in the modern
history of America but we cannot simply
be consumed by Donald Trump because if
we are you know what we're gonna lose
the election American people understand
is that the Congress can walk and chew
bubble gum at the same time in other
words we can deal with Trump's
corruption but we also have to stand up
for the working families of this country
joseline ch Mitchell is assistant
professor at the Northwestern University
in Qatar she joins us here in the studio
in Doha Jocelyn saige Wilson who won the
democratic debate thank you for having
me well you know one of the biggest
questions was will Biden finally win a
democratic debate you know he is the
national poll front-runner and
considered to be the the main candidate
right now and yet the perceived
weaknesses of his candidacy have created
not only opportunities for the moderates
in the race currently but also moderates
to enter the race late we see Michael
Bloomberg and devil Patrick for example
entering because of perceived weakness
of Biden's candidacy so it's very
important for him to have a strong
debate tonight he did have strong
moments he was able to talk about the
respect for the rule of law and on the
importance of stability in our politics
as well as an interesting and critical
take on Saudi Arabia's human rights
violations including bringing up Jamal
khashoggi so that was quite interesting
for me but he was relatively weak still
and shaky on some of the core issues of
the Democratic Party such as gender
equality
with the me to movement and the question
of drug policies and general
authenticity regarding race and the
black community in America so in sum
Biden had a relatively strong debate but
it wasn't a slam dunk for him and
they'll still be some some question
marks around his candidacy going forward
going forward to those individual
candidates have to kind of refocus what
they're doing if only because they spent
so much time talking about the
impeachment inquiry it's almost as if
the democratic process is being defined
as a function of Donald Trump yes well I
agree with you that there was a focus on
the impeachment especially at the
beginning I actually thought it was a
really good move on the part of the
debate organizers to start with the
question because it's the elephant in
the room or the circus in Washington DC
you might say but at the same time I
don't think they dwelled on it because
the candidates really don't have any
daylight between them on this issue
virtually everyone on that stage agrees
that President Trump may have committed
impeachable offenses and that it's
important for Congress to take seriously
their their constitutional duty to
protect our democracy so after that
original question we we seem to move
forward into actually quite a
substantive and strong debate for many
candidates you know it was interesting
the speculation at the beginning of this
of this debate previous was that Peabody
Judge may get a lot of attacks by his
fellow candidates and this is because he
has just had a very strong polling in
the state of Iowa and and the reason why
Iowa is important is because it's the
first state for the primaries in in
February of this next year and he was
the top the top candidate in that recent
poll but we didn't actually see this
huge ganging up on on Pete Budaj edge we
did see Elizabeth Warren once again have
an extremely strong debate the main
focus was on her from the start she
dominated the first hour finished
strongly ended up with the most speaking
time but actually all four of the top
tier candidates including Bernie Sanders
Joe Biden and pipa de jedge had strong
debates and so did the second tier
candidates
Cory Booker Kamala Harris and and also
Amy Klobuchar
and the most important thing here was
that the message and tone overall was
this message of civility and unity it's
very clear that the Democrats are trying
to portray themselves as the adults in
the room in direct contrast to the
circus that is the Trump White House in
a time of social media in a time of
spin-doctors and spin and Twitter and
just to be clear politicians telling
lies on social media platforms how long
until the Democratic candidates the
Democrat candidates choose to or are
allowed to pitch themselves based on the
bread-and-butter issues you know how
much money you've got in the bank how
much tax you're paying whether your job
is secure the kind of things that people
really want to vote on I like I said you
know there were a lot of substantive
issues covered in this particular debate
there could still have been so much more
I mean we we we didn't discuss economic
inequality at all we didn't discuss
issues in the the public education
system we didn't discuss gun violence
and these are important issues that
Americans care about and they want to
hear more about these issues but we did
discuss very important issues including
what I appreciated was a focus on
climate change that was a very important
thing to focus on we had it we had a
good set of remarks on that and certain
candidates kept coming back to that we
also had some really interesting things
brought up for example about child care
and paid family leave the importance of
military and other types of service to
our country so there are a lot of issues
on the minds of Americans and in each of
these debates we we're trying to touch
on them we'll see what happens with the
December debate okay we have to leave it
there Justin sage Mitchell from
Northwestern here in Qatar thank you so
much thank you